Відповідальні обчислення розуміються
як розробка квантових обчислень
з усвідомленням їхньої потужності
та потенційного впливу. Коли ми говоримо «відповідальні»,
ми маємо на увазі розробку та використання технологій
на основі заздалегідь визначених принципів, щоб запобігати
та пом'якшувати потенційну шкоду,
водночас просуваючи рішення, що проактивно
інклюзивні та підзвітні. В IBM
нами десятиліттями керує відчуття відповідальності
перед суспільством. Сьогодні ми називаємо себе каталізатором,
який робить світ кращим. Це означає, що ми
маємо відповідальність враховувати наслідки
технологій, які ми створюємо та допомагаємо впроваджувати.
Розробляючи цю нову технологію,
рішення, які ми приймаємо сьогодні, впливатимуть на майбутнє,
і ці рішення
здатні мати величезний вплив на суспільство.
Наприклад, тобі може знадобитися вирішити — розвивати застосунок,
який допомагає лише кільком стейкхолдерам, чи
той, що може розв'язати суспільну проблему.
Ми сподіваємося, що ти, як клієнт, зможеш думати
про відповідальний розвиток квантових обчислень.
Відповідальне мислення допоможе твоєму бізнесу завоювати довіру
інвесторів і споживачів,
а також сформувати репутацію доброчесності
та поваги серед твоїх співробітників
і клієнтів. З іншого боку,
це може захистити тебе від негативної преси, штрафів
та санкцій. У цьому відео
ми розглянемо важливі міркування щодо відповідальності,
які варто обговорити з командою,
поки ти досліджуєш квантові обчислення
та їхні застосунки. Говорячи про квантові обчислення,
думати та діяти відповідально —
означає дотримуватися набору принципів
і цінностей, що спрямовують твою розробку
та розгортання технологій.
Наприклад, це означає бути прозорим
як щодо обмежень, так і можливостей
квантових обчислень сьогодні. У нас є мова
в наших контрактах, яка вимагає від клієнтів IBM Quantum
використовувати наші системи відповідально
і не використовувати наші системи
для злочинних або незаконних цілей.
Ми називаємо це нашими положеннями про відповідальне
та допустиме використання.
Ця мова вже впливає на те, як наші клієнти думають
про розробку квантових рішень
для своїх сценаріїв використання. Ми також можемо
впливати на напрямок розвитку квантових обчислень,
вирішуючи, які застосунки ми розвиваємо
для розробки та прискорення.
Щоб захиститися від потенційно безвідповідального використання
наших технологій, ми також розробили надійну квантово-безпечну технологію IBM.
Коли ти думаєш про те, як
і навіщо використовувати квантові обчислення,
переконайся, що реалістично говориш про свої очікування
щодо квантових обчислень і терміни,
в які ти сподіваєшся впровадити квантові рішення.
Не представляй квантові обчислення
як щось загадкове — натомість намагайся пояснювати їх реалістично
як обчислювальне залізо,
що підпорядковується законам квантової фізики.
Переконайся, що твій сценарій використання квантових обчислень
є проактивно інклюзивним
і враховує всіх потенційних стейкхолдерів,
щоб визначити масштаб
будь-яких негативних соціальних наслідків.
Переконайся, що ти визначив чіткі принципи
та цінності для дослідження свого сценарію використання
та розробки. Дякуємо
за перегляд. Ми сподіваємося, що
коли ти принесеш корисні квантові обчислення у світ,
ти також думатимеш про те, як робити це відповідально.
Ну що ж.